[Music]
we have new details tonight as two
passengers who survived last friday's
fatal bus crash near the grand canyon
file a lawsuit against the tour bus
company 8 news now anchor sasha loftis
spoke with an attorney representing the
passengers and also the owner of comedy
on deck
tours she joins us now in the newsroom
with the latest
denise and brian this lawsuit details
the physical and emotional pain those
two passengers say could be quote
permanent and disabling the bus which
was operated by
las vegas-based comedy on deck tours was
headed to the grand canyon on january
22nd
when it crashed in northwestern arizona
one woman was killed and dozens of
others were hurt
including those who filed this suit the
driver of the bus
also named the plaintiff's claim he was
speeding and quote driving
negligently they're going to have
medical expenses they're they're likely
to have
psychological expensive expenses and all
that should be compensated for
in a fair in a fair way the lawsuit also
says the owners of comedy on deck tours
were responsible for the driver's
training and supervision
i spoke with the owner on the phone
tonight he did not want to go on camera
he said he and his wife are quote
devastated by this
now the lawsuit is seeking over 50
thousand dollars in damages
but the attorney i spoke with tonight
says it isn't possible to name exactly
how much money is being saw here
because the two passengers do not know
the exact extent
of their injuries just yet reporting in
the newsroom tonight sasha loftis
8 news now